5 25 on your Wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy well if you drive
regularly on Charleston you know it can
be a tough ride especially in a couple
of specific areas
today's story with possible alternates
which could be even more helpful for
folks who get caught unaware in the big
backups at these trouble spots we've for
sure talked about the closure of
westbound Charleston heading toward the
95 515 part of the Nevada Department of
transportation's improvement project
there The Squeeze down to two lanes can
tie you up all the way back to land and
if that happens to you try getting off
Charleston at lamb we can go North to
Bonanza then West to Eastern with a
short easy left turn down Eastern right
to the freeway you can also go south on
land to where it curves to become di
with a quick right turn north on Boulder
Highway where the freeways right after
Boulder Station now the other stretch of
Charleston between Eastern and Bruce
that's being repaved but until then I
think Sahara might be a better bet
and if you think Charleston's a pain oh
that's nothing compared to indot's
complete closure of both directions of
the 15 between Flamingo and Russell
that's coming up later this month stay
tuned for more on Tropicana buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone you can join the revenue crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com